[Music]
they just announced the honorary degree
recipients for 2018 just saw the post
two times any winner a Hollywood Walk of
Fame saving the oceans and then there's
her girl brown Jacon Jacon crypto genius
turn work yes that means so proud of
stem alumna well chemistry rock star
it's awesome
she say DNA pioneer my opinion
antibiotic innovator
[Music]
he note though he's got mad investing
schools really the most successful hedge
fund investor ever and he gives back but
Jude oMG and the student speaker though
raise big money for the donut dad it's
me join 28 teens honorary degree
recipients and me Kevin Wayne Zach at
commencement on May 20th 2018
congratulations class of 2018
[Music]